cet arbuste qui réagit au contact humain
à l'énergie électrostatique s'appelle
fono folle y sommes une installation
hybride qui fait partie des quatre
oeuvres de l'exposition scenocosme
installé aux prises miles en cours des
créations singulières qui ont toutes un
dénominateur commun
nous explorons beaucoup la question de
toucher de la relation à l'eau de la
relation à l'élément naturel dans toutes
nos installations interactives la place
du corps est toujours très importante et
nous interrogeons en fait nos relations
contemporaines
aujourd'hui avec ses différents
environnements et également nous
interroge aussi la place de la
technologie dans notre environnement
naturel et social de quelle manière nous
vivons avec un univers visuel et sonore
dans lequel vous pouvez notamment créé
en temps réel des mises en scènes
narratives rencontre imaginaire est une
série de plusieurs oeuvres vidéo
interactive comportementale light
contact met en scène le corps et la peau
des spectateurs
[Musique]
lorsqu'une première personne pose la
main sur la bible ne se passe rien elle
doit aller venir toucher une deuxième
personne pour rendre entendre un son et
prouver une lumière qui va varier en
fonction de l'intensité énergétique de
cette relation
c'est une troisième personne quatrième
personne vient se rajouter à cette
chaîne humaine leçon va aussi se
modifier bien que présentes dans toutes
ses installations la technologie n'est
jamais visibles les expériences
proposées par scenocosme sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 21 février
[Musique]